>>> THE ALWAYS CONTROVERSIAL
"SOUTH PARK" IS AT IT AGAIN.
THIS TIME TAKING ON THE
CONTROVERSIAL GUN CONTROL.
>> THERE'S NOBODY WE COULD
TRUST.
>> WHAT DO WE DO NOW?
>> WE HAVE TO GET GUNS.
>> GUNS?
>> IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO BE SAFE.
>> IF WE THOUGHT IT WOULD
PROTECT US, HOW CAN WE GET OUR
HANDS ON GUNS?
ALL RIGHT, COOL, WE GOT GUNS.
SO NOW WHAT?
>> I ALREADY FEEL A LOT SAFER.
>> TO DISCUSS THIS CNN'S BRIAN
STELTZER JOINS US NOW.
WHAT'S THE REACTION TO THIS?
>> ALL SEASON THEY'VE BEEN GOING
AFTER POLITICALLY CORRECT
CULTURE, SAYING THE PC CULTURE
IS DESTROYING AMERICA.
IN AMERICA THEY'RE TAKING ON
GUNS.
HERE'S ANOTHER CLIP FROM LAST
NIGHT'S EPISODE.
>> I TOLD YOU TO GO UPSTAIRS
RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, MOM, WHAT THE HELL?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU
AGAIN, ERIC, IT IS TIME FOR
NIGHT-NIGHT.
>> MOM, PUT DOWN YOUR GUN.
>> I AM YOUR MOTHER AND YOU WILL
DO WHAT I TELL YOU.
>> I AM GOING.
>> THEN YOU GO RIGHT NOW,
MISTER.
>> I'M GOING, MOM.
>> NO COMIC BOOKS.
STRAIGHT TO SLEEP.
I LOVE YOU.
>> I LOVE YOU TOO, MOM.
NIGHT-NIGHT.
>> WOW, HE -- HE LISTENED.
>> KIND OF LIKE A RORSCHACH
TEST.
CAN YOU TAKE AWAY FROM IT
WHATEVER YOU THINK.
YOU CAN THINK TYPICAL HOLLYWOOD
LIBERALS MAKING HOW HORRIBLE IT
IS WHEN EVERYONE HAS GUB.
BUT THERE WAS NO HORRIBLE
SHOOTOUT OR VIOLENCE IN THE
EPISODE WHICH I SEE SOME
CONSERVATIVE BLOGS CHEERING
SAYING LIBERALS DIDN'T GET THE
MOMENT THEY WANTED FROM THIS
SHOW.
IT'S A SILLY COMEDY, CARTOON
CHARACTERS BUT THE CREATORS MAKE
THESE EPISODES SO QUICKLY, THEY
PRODUCE THEM JUST DAYS AHEAD